so one of the biggest questions that
fans have had since the hogwarts legacy
gameplay revealed back in march will we
be able to play quidditch and today i'm
reporting that according to multiple
sources close to the project hogwarts
legacy will not feature playable
quidditch please donate the messenger
guys and honestly don't hate on
avalanche either i understand it i'll
explain why now i'm sure you all have so
many questions so i'm going to try and
answer several of what i anticipate will
be the most frequently asked questions
i'll also explain why i'm personally
okay with this decision here in a bit
but first i think it's important to note
this does not mean quidditch will be
completely absent from the world in
hogwarts legacy i mean it's not like
they're going to pretend it doesn't
exist or something i mean if you think
back to the gameplay reveal trailer it
clearly shows the quidditch pitch and
what appears to be characters wearing
quidditch robes then you have the asmr
video which also gave us a look at
quality quidditch supplies so quidditch
will still be part of this world it may
even factor into the story we may even
see people playing quidditch i don't
know what i'm confirming today though is
that it will not be playable for our
character alright so let's try and
tackle some of those questions that i
know you have and i expect the biggest
one to be why why would they not include
quidditch well if you go back to the
2020 blog post from adrian rob he said
quote often the difficult task is
choosing which details we aren't going
to explore close quote i honestly think
it was simply a matter of managing the
resources and trying to decide what all
they wanted to include from the
wizarding world simply because there is
so much it's such a deep and rich world
some sacrifices had to be made in
another blog post from community manager
chandler wood he said he asked game
director alan tu what fans love and
expect from the wizarding world and that
their resulting conversations could fill
tomes because of the sheer amount of
everything that could be included then
chandler goes on to try and get him to
narrow it down to just two sentences and
two told him quote the most ever-present
part of the wizarding world is its magic
and the playful nature and realness of
its distinct rules should fuel a
surprising dark mystery that tests the
combined resources of those who discover
it but just as important are the
opportunities to experience hundreds of
memorable moments small and large that
fans grew up with and know by heart from
being sorted in the great hall exploring
a new secret chamber in hogwarts or
impersonating others with polyjuice
potion to protecting innocents from a
dangerous troll dodging fireballs from a
hungarian horntail or soaring into the
sky on the back of a friendly hippogriff
i mean that is one heck of a list right
there guys and seemingly confirmation
that we're gonna get all of those or
something close to that in hogwarts
legacy and really this is part of the
reason that i'm okay with this decision
and i understand it trust me i know
there are a lot of you out there who are
going to be really upset by this who
really wanted quidditch trust me i get
it but think about it like this for a
second would you really have wanted them
to devote a ton of time and resources to
focusing on quidditch which was big
enough to get its own full game back
with harry potter quidditch world cup
years ago when they could instead be
focusing on perfecting say the spell
casting system or fleshing out more
story details what about adding more
hidden passages in hogwarts or working
on the vendors and cosmetic upgrades in
hogsmeade i mean as much as i love
quidditch there are plenty of other
things on that list that i think are
much more important and i think as fans
we just have to trust that this is going
to make for a better overall game as it
does allow avalanche to focus on the
most important parts of an action rpg
which let's be honest here the story the
spells the gameplay mechanics of spell
casting the collectibles side quest
hogwarts itself and all of the secrets
are just far more important than
including playable quidditch which truth
be told would really be a side activity
that not even everyone would want to
participate in i mean let's try and
think about it like this if they did try
and include playable quidditch then they
would have to make even more sacrifices
like is it part of the story to have the
player character participate or do we
make it a completely optional thing and
if it's only optional then how do we
really justify spending a lot of time
and resources on this should they force
them into the secret position like we
did with harry or do they try and
include all the positions do they have a
quidditch cup that sets matches against
other houses i mean the list goes on and
on another question i expect to get on
this is how sure i am and can i reveal
the sources i would say i'm about 98
sure barring something drastic changing
i'm about 98 sure that this will be true
i'm very confident in these sources and
no unfortunately i cannot disclose them
that's just not how this works guys and
if you choose not to believe look
totally okay by me i get it you're right
to be skeptical i'm not an ign i'm not a
gamestop i'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell another
expected question do i think there's
still time to add quidditch or could we
get it later on so definite no on the
first one but on the second one i'll say
maybe in that blog post i mentioned alan
2 had a line near the end where he said
with your continued support we hope to
explore even more in the future as soon
as i read that it immediately sounded to
me like the possibility of dlc and maybe
even sequel so i do think and this is
purely me guessing here no sources or
anything on this i do think if this game
is successful and they continue to hear
a strong fan desire for quidditch they
could very well look into adding it
later down the line maybe as post-launch
dlc i mean we do have to remember we
know that flying on a broom is 100 for
sure in the game so they would already
have that kind of bass line to help them
if they wanted to build a quidditch game
on top of that but then we get into that
question of resources again would fans
really want an added quidditch mode more
so than say a new story dlc i mean if
i'm wb i think these are all things that
they would be listening to if this game
is successful which i think it will be
they're going to be listening to the
fans what are the fans want more of what
are the fans want out of hogwarts legacy
do the fans want a completely new game
who knows maybe someone would even
consider a brand new quidditch world cup
game if there's enough demand honestly
this would be my personal preference i
would love if a developer whether it's
avalanche or someone else was given the
proper time and care to be able to make
a fully developed standalone quidditch
game with multiplayer i'd much prefer
that in sort of a small tact on mode to
hogwarts legacy but i mean i could see
it going either way depending on the fan
reaction and fan response now while
today's news story answers one of the
big questions that we still had about
the game there are still plenty that we
don't know the answer to in fact i've
already made a video on the top
questions that i still have for hogwarts
legacy you can check it out on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon